The Star Wars saga has returned to the big
screen and fans couldn’t be happier.
As the record-breaking box office numbers
indicate, moviegoers have been going to the
theater multiple times to see the new film.
And while the story and performances make
repeat viewings worthwhile, there are also
a ton of Easter eggs in the movie for audiences
to seek out next time they watch it.
Here are Screen Rant’s 10 Amazing Hidden
Details in Star Wars: The Force Awakens.
The Falcon’s New Dish
At the end of Return of the Jedi, the Millennium
Falcon gets banged up a little bit, losing
its circular radar dish in the Battle of Endor.
Some replacements were in order, and they
apparently took place before The Force Awakens.
In the new film, the iconic ship has a rectangular
radar dish, creating a necessary link between
the original and sequel trilogies.
It only makes sense that the Falcon would
have a new design after being damaged.
It’s a nice attention to detail that honors
the franchise’s history in a subtle way.
If the Falcon looked the same, it wouldn’t
seem right.
Ello Asty
J.J. Abrams loves the Beastie Boys, incorporating
some of their classic tunes like “Sabotage”
and “Body Movin’” into his Star Trek
pictures.
Because Star Wars doesn’t take place on
Earth, the rap group couldn’t be worked
into the Episode 7 soundtrack, but Abrams
still found a way to pay tribute to the musical
legends.
A Resistance pilot featured in the film is
named Ello Asty, a reference to the Beastie
Boys’ Grammy winning album, Hello Nasty.
The writing on the side of his helmet reads
“Born to Ill,” which is a nod to the Beasties’
debut record, Licensed to Ill.
007: Stormtrooper
It was long rumored that James Bond star Daniel
Craig was going to cameo as a First Order
stormtrooper in The Force Awakens, a report
Craig himself denied.
But when the film hit theaters, 007 was there
underneath the armor.
He’s the victim of Rey’s Jedi Mind Trick
as she escapes from captivity in Starkiller
base.
It’s hard to pick up at first, but if you
listen closely, Craig’s voice is unmistakable
as he follows Rey’s commands to break her
bonds… and drop his gun.
It’s a comedic moment and shows that even
A-list actors will happily take a cameo to
be part of the Star Wars legacy.
FN-2187
When audiences first meet protagonist Finn,
he’s known only by his First Order call
signal: FN-2187.
Poe Dameron is the one who combines the letters
to create the name Finn, but the numbers are
what hold a greater meaning to fans of the
original trilogy.
2187 was the number of the prison cell that
contained Princess Leia on the first Death
Star in the adventure that started it all.
It’s a clever bit of fan service that doesn’t
hit moviegoers over the head with an obvious
homage.
All it does is service the story while operating
as a fun reveal for those who have been there
since the beginning.
Luke’s Training Remote
Going back on board the Millennium Falcon
was sure to be a trip down memory lane, and
Abrams dialed up the nostalgia when Rey and
Finn board the ship.
As the two search through the Falcon’s contents,
Finn pulls the training remote from A New
Hope out of a bag, giving it a confused look
before he tosses it aside.
It’s only on screen for a brief moment,
but if you don’t blink and miss it, its
appearance will conjure up images of the scene
where Luke truly starts his Jedi training
and takes his first steps into a larger world.
How Many Parsecs?
Fans may never truly understand the mythology
of the Kessel Run, since parsecs are a measurement
of distance, not time.
Still, Han Solo knows he accomplished the
feat in just 12 parsecs, and is very proud
of that fact.
When he meets Rey and Finn, Rey exclaims that
the Falcon is the ship that completed the
Run in 14 parsecs.
Han is quick to correct her – those two
parsecs making a big difference in his mind.
It’s similar to an aging athlete recalling
a great game, remembering every little detail
just as it happened.
And for fans, it’s an extra laugh in a movie
full of them.
Ben Solo
Viewers learn that villain Kylo Ren is actually
Ben Solo, son of Han and Leia.
While the origins of the name are never revealed,
it could be a nod to “Ben” Kenobi, the
one partly responsible for bringing Han and
Leia together.
Another interpretation is that Kylo’s birth
name is a reference to Ben Skywalker, the
child of Luke and Mara Jade in the now discontinued
Star Wars Legends novel series, which are
not canon.
Either way, it seems like Abrams was tipping
his hat to the series history when he named
the new movie’s antagonist.
Voices of the Force
One of the most talked-about sequences in
the film is when Rey touches Luke’s old
lightsaber and has a Force vision.
There’s a lot going on, including some vocal
cameos by the Jedi who trained Luke.
Frank Oz recorded some lines as Yoda and both
actors that played Obi-Wan are there as well.
Ewan McGregor’s voice tells Rey that “these
are your first steps,” and clever editing
allowed the late Alec Guinness to reprise
his iconic role.
Crew members took the actor saying “afraid”
and turned it to “Rey.”
There may not be any Force ghosts in Episode
VII, but the presence of the old Masters is
still felt.
BB-8’s Human Voice
Fans instantly fell in love with new droid
BB-8 thanks to his cute appearance and personality.
A lot of the credit has to be given to the
two human comedians that provided the robot’s
voice.
Abrams attached his iPad to a talk box operated
by SNL alum Bill Hader, using a sound effects
app on his device to get the right voice.
Parks and Recreation actor Ben Schwartz also
provided a helping hand, earning a credit
as a vocal consultant.
Maybe that’s why BB-8 was such a hit with
viewers.
He came pre-packaged with a human touch.
R2-KT
Star Wars fans are familiar with the story
of R2-KT, the astromech droid that 501st Legion
member Albin Johnson had built for his daughter
Katie when she was diagnosed with terminal
cancer.
R2-KT has become a fixture of Star Wars media
ever since, appearing in the Clone Wars animated
series and attending various fan conventions.
Abrams gave the droid her live-action screen
debut in The Force Awakens.
As Poe reunites with Finn at the Resistance
base, R2-KT can be seen under the pilot’s
X-wing fighter, a touching moment for those
who are aware of the character’s creation
and the heartfelt meaning behind it.
Those are our picks for amazing hidden details
in The Force Awakens.
Are there any we missed?
Which ones are your favorites?
Sound off in the comments below and be sure
to subscribe to our channel for more videos
like this one.